انها المواجهه التي كان اكثر الناس يعلمون
انها واقعه يوما ما
فالحروب لا تنشا اعتباطا ولكنها تتخلق من
اسبابها الظاهره والخفيه حتى تكتمل شروطها
فتندلع
والحرب التي تشير اليوم الموت والدمار في
العاصمه السودانيه وفي اطراف البلاد من
غربها في الفاشر ونياله الى مدينه مروي في
شمال السودان وكسل والقضارف شرقا
هي حرب تضرب جذورها في بيئه سياسيه مدنيه
وعسكريه مشحونه بالعداء وبسوء الظن
والتوجس الاطراف بعضها من بعض
في التعريف البسيط هي حرب بين الجيش وبين
الدعم السريع في تعريف اكثر دقه وتعقيدا
هي حرب الجميع ضد الجميع
هي التجلي العنيف للازمه السياسيه
العسكريه التي اتهم المدنيون والعسكر على
حد سواء بالتواطؤ على تغطيتها بارضيه
الكلام حتى يظن الظن ان الحرب اخر ما يفكر
فيه العسكريون اخر ما يفكر فيه الفريقان
البرهان قائد الجيش
قائد الدعم السريع الدعم السريع كلنا نعلم
تماما الا زوال مكابر والله زول منافق ما
يعلم ادواره قامت بها مش هي حفظ هذه
الثوره في كل السودان وما كان حميدتي باقل
من البرهان في نفي شبهه اي خلاف بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
لكن الحرب التي تدور الان رغم كل ذلك هي
حرب ينرالين وحرب جيشين انها المواجهه
التي كانت نذرها تملك الفضاء
[موسيقى]
فالفريق البرهان يعيش تحت ضغط كثير من
ضباط جيشه الذين لا يخفون تدمرهم من تنام
قوات الدعم السريع وازدياد سطوه ونفوذ
قائدها
واما القائد حميتي فهو ايضا ضحيه فائض
القوه المتراكمه ثروه وعتادا حربيا ورجالا
وتفريطه في كل ذلك سيعني انكشافه ونهايته
ما يصنع بهذه القوه اذن ينفذ انقلابا
لحيازه السلطه كامله تقول بيانه الجيش
التي وصفته وقواته بالتمرد
اما الفريق البرهان فهو ايضا يمتلئ بطموح
للحكم تقضيه رؤيه والده بانه سيكون ذا شان
عظيم وكانت زيارته السريه للقاء نتنياهو
في اوغندا قبل اكثر من ثلاث سنوات ارهاصا
برغبته الملحه في تامين مستقبل سياسي ربما
راى ان اسرائيل
ستتعهده بالرعايه كما ان البرهان في زعم
المناويعيه واقع تحت ضغط المكون العسكري
الاسلامي داخل الجيش فضلا عن المدنيين
خارجه فما اكثر ما اتهم بانه وراء عوده
الاسلاميين الى مواقع متنفذه في الدوله
وبهذا المعنى فان الحرب ستكون قطعا للطريق
امام توقيع الاتفاق الايطالي الذي كان
سياخذ البلاد في مسار يضر بطموحات البرهان
السياسيه ويسد كل طريق على الاسلاميين
المبعدين عن ممارسه العمل السياسي
هذا المشهد المحتقن بين الجمرلين تتحلق
حوله قوى سياسيه مدنيه
تستظهر بقوتهما في اداره الصراع بينها
فانقلاب البرهان كما وصفته قوه مدنيه او
ما يعرف بقراراته في الخامس والعشرين من
اكتوبر العام قبل الماضي كانت تقف وراءه
كتله منشقه عن الحريه والتغيير عرفت بمثاق
التوافق الوطني ضمت احزابا وحركات مسلحه
مسالمه كانت توقيعهم على الميثاق في
السادسه عشر من اكتوبر بعد تسعه ايام فقط
يصدر البرهان قراراته منهيا مسار الحكم
المدني ومعتقلا رئيس الوزراء عبد الله
حمدوك وزاجا بكثير من وزرائه في المعتقلان
ولم يمضي وقت كثير حتى وجدت الجماعه
السياسيه المدنيه نفسها خارج اللعبه
السياسيه وعادت العمليه السياسيه لتقرب
طرائد الامس من الحريه التغيير المجلس
المركزي الى قلب الفعل السياسي عبر مشروع
جديد عرف بالاتفاق الايطالي وهو الاتفاق
الذي سيتعهد الفريق
بحمايته شخصيا وعبر الدعم السريع لتحقيق
انتقال ديمقراطي بحكم مدني كامل
وسريعا ستتحول الحريه والتغيير ومن شايعها
من القوه الى حاضنه مدنيه للفريق
الذي اتهم من قبل بازدراء سعيها الى
الديمقراطيه والمدنيه وانه سخر منها مرارا
ايام التفاوض على قسمه السلطه اول شهور
الثوره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشهد ما قبل المواجهه هو ان الذين كانوا
سببا لصداع حميتي قد اصبحوا حلفائه والذين
كانوا حلفاء البرحان قبيل قراراته قد
اصبحوا ضحاياه السياسيين وهم ينكرون عليه
انكار الاسلاميين المضي في مسار الاتفاق
الايطالي وهو اتفاق في المحصله النهائيه
ضد مصالح البرهان السياسيه اما النقوص عن
ذلك الاتفاق فهو سيشكل خطرا على طموحاتهم
السياسيه والعسكريه فالاتفاق يضمن له ابدا
لدمج قواته في الجيش يبلغ 10 سنوات وهكذا
سيبدو الدمج والخلاف حوله في الظاهر هو
القشه التي قصمت ظهر بعير مثقل بالاحمال
والاخطاء والخطايا والمطامع في نظر
الطوائف من الشعب على الاقل
مطامع الجنرال اللذين روع المواطنين واشاع
القتل في عشر رمضان الاواخر تذكر بما كانا
قد فعلاه في عشر من رمضان قبل ثلاث سنوات
كان قتلا يوم ذاك من اجل السلطه وهو
اقتتال اليوم على مذبحها ايضا ومن الناس
القرابين
امس واليوم